and speaking of the franchise tag the
lions have a candidate
in receiver kenny galladay dan campbell
new head coach addressing the media
today talking about
the possibility of tagging kenny
gallaudet and dusting off an old take
about whether or not it's actually a
good thing to be tagged here's campbell
well i would love to be franchised that
would be nice because that's
it's a pretty good it's a pretty good
little chunk right now but
i don't want to get that far into it i
really don't michael i'm sorry
uh look all these things will be coming
down the road you know before the 17th
obviously
and uh you know look we've we've had
dialogue we've talked back and forth
brad and i have talked about this i mean
we've gone every scenario you could go
down
believe it or not just on everybody
dan campbell said recently he doesn't
care if people view him as a meat head
and that's good
that's very good that he doesn't care
because as archie bunker once said to
his son-in-law dead from the neck up
meat head come on it's not a good thing
to be franchise tagged yeah it's a nice
payday for one year but what it does
and when a head coach says something
like this fans in media get twisted up
about whether or not it really is a good
thing
it's not a good thing it is an
impediment on the ability of the player
to get maximum value on the open market
and to get generational wealth
through a long-term deal that pays out
in fully guaranteed increments
a hell of a lot more than what that
franchise tag is going to be
so the team uses it not as a favor to
the player
the team uses it as a favor to itself to
limit what the guy makes
to keep him from hitting the open market
and then controlling his rights for
another year meanwhile he's the one
carrying the injury risk
he's the one bearing the risk that he's
not going to be as attractive to another
team a year from now
as he is now he's got to get through 16
more games
and stay at the level he's at to get the
payday next year
shireen that he should have gotten this
year and it's all gonna fall just right
for him to get that payday next year
that he should have gotten this year so
please coach campbell don't tell us
don't insult
our intelligence i mean i've got limited
intelligence so when it's insulted i get
pissed
don't try to tell me it's a good thing
for a player to be franchise tag
i thought we crossed that bridge 25
years ago shireen okay let's back up one
second to aaron jones you said you would
sign the tag immediately if it's 11
does it depend on the player and the
position are you
like that across the board or is that
just for this year on aaron jones
it's running back and if i'm aaron jones
and they're going to keep me from the
market i'll take i'll take my eight
figures because of the position because
here's the thing
and this is why i don't know why the
packers would
use the franchise tag on him this was
explained to me
last year in the context of one of the
running backs who signed a long-term
contract with his current team and i
believe
this analysis the situation running
backs
only get big money long-term deals from
the team that they became
a star with you hit the market you're
melvin gordon at 8 million a year
that's why if i'm aaron jones i'm saying
hey if you're going to pay me 11.1
million this year
i'll take it because you may wake up one
day and realize
i i shouldn't be tagged so in his unique
situation
yeah i guess you could say it's not bad
because he's getting a payday that
he's not gonna get an average contract
to that amount on the open market i've
seen suggestions you're gonna get 15
million i believe it when i see it
but generally speaking it's not you're
not doing the player
a favor and i guarantee you that kenny
gallaudet if he hits the open market
is going to sign a contract with fully
guaranteed money that dwarfs
whatever the franchise tag ends up being
for receivers this year so i just i just
don't like that because what it does
it it it lies to the fans
and it also gets some in the media who
for whatever reason want to take an
anti-player position it gives them some
raw meat that they can use to try to get
the fans on the side of this notion that
the players are being greedy why do you
want so much isn't it enough
for you to get this nice chunk of change
why do you want so much more i'm over
that i'm sick of that
these guys are the ones putting their
asses on the line every week these guys
are the ones who
are going across that thick white stripe
out of the football field and assuming
the risk of injury
and it makes it even more offensive to
players that a former player
would spout that crap that dan campbell
spouted today
all due respect i'm gonna
back up to to last year when we had
players tag mike you look at two of the
players tagged
bud dupree and dak prescott and i think
prescott i think we both agree he's
still going to get his money he's still
going to get paid but
bud dupree i'm going to be surprised
mike if he doesn't sign a one-year deal
coming off an acl injury i mean this was
bad for him he could have signed a huge
contract
and gotten that generational money and
he's not going to get that now he's
going to have to come back
off that acl injury and prove himself
yet again to get that big contract that
he could have had
a year ago so sometimes it works out for
players sometimes it doesn't work out
for players but i know you want to sign
the long-term deal when you get the
chance to sign the long-term deal you
look at
joe mixon joe mixon ended up signing his
long-term deal
got 12 million a year got hurt right he
wouldn't get that money this year if he
hadn't signed that long-term deal so
i always think if you get that long-term
deal you need to sign it you need to
make sure that you're going to get your
money
and not just play i know that we talk
about betting on yourself and all that
sort of stuff but
there are just too many injuries in this
game normally to bet on yourself
and it's easier for the quarterback to
say i'm going to go year to year
kirk cousins blaze that trail of all
quarterbacks he blazed that trail
for the quarterback position dak
prescott is following that path
trumaine johnson blazed that trail for
defensive backs the same year that kirk
cousins did people forget about trumaine
johnson
he went two tags with the rams hit the
open market got a big contract from the
jets never lived up to it but you know
what
he's laying on a stack of money like the
guy from breaking bad somewhere right
now a big pile of cash and a storage
unit that's
all his and always will be he played the
game
and he won so uh and and you know with
with dak
one of the arguments i hear all the time
is well what's he really worth on the
market what's he worth what's he worth
we don't know what he's worth because
the cowboys keep blocking him from going
to the market
that's the thing the franchise tag is a
tool used by teams
to keep players from maximizing the
return
on their abilities and their sacrifices
i've never liked that i've accepted it
that was part of the the trade-off to
get free agency
but uh the teams love it the teams use
it and 25 years later here we are still
litigating the question of whether or
not it's a good thing for players or not
generally it is a bad thing and i just
think that players who hear any coach
gm owner or anyone tied to a team saying
otherwise
should be upset about that shireen
if you're talking about kenny gallaudet
mike he's 27
played five games in 2020 20 catches 338
yards
two touchdowns but that you look at the
lions they have
all the receiving core are free agents
kenny galladey marvin jones danny
amendola
mohamed sanu they're all free agents so
if you're the lions
and you're in that position do you
franchise kenny gallaudet i think he
will be franchised but would you
franchise it
i probably would not i probably would
not because he walks away as a free
agent you get compensatory draft pick
consideration now the problem is they
may be thinking about spending
money on a lot of different free agents
because if you sign more than you lose
you don't get anything for kenny
gallaudet
that's how the formula works and it's
far more nuanced than that but the more
guys you sign
the less it matters that you had a guy
leave but yeah i don't know if they've
got some twisted logic here where
they're gonna tag and trade him
i i just don't know but but just don't
don't just don't don't tell me it's a
good thing if it happens it's not a good
thing if it happens it's it's
rarely anything you could even remotely
argue
is a good thing for a player it keeps
the player from going to the market and
getting the best
deal that he possibly can
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports